como puede ver detrás de mí hay
muchísima energía electoral miles de
personas han pasado por este punto de la
avenida paulista la más importante de
Sao Paulo estamos a la altura del museo
más uno también de los más emblemáticos
de San Pablo sobre la paulista van
varias comparsas pasando estos organizó
a manera de carnaval Lula da Silva
entregó declaraciones a la prensa junto
a la candidato a la gobernación
y después lo que se tiene planteado es
que se va a unir a los locos políticos
que le apoyan entre bueno todos los
grupos que están ahora como con Lula da
Silva
le han denominado la marcha de la
Victoria así que bueno vamos a ver qué
es lo que pasa mañana pero en la previa
digamos que hay muchísima emoción de los
dulistas y usted mencionaba hace un
momento sobre las encuestas Y sí han
salido nuevas encuestas está por ejemplo
la de mda que le da a Lula un 51,1% y a
bolsonaro 48,9% y Paraná pesquisas
para Lula y 49,6% para bolsonaro por
supuesto esto solamente marca una
posible tendencia Pero lo que sí podemos
decir con certeza es que es una duro
retrato de la realidad muy polarizada a
unas elecciones sumamente apretadas
posiblemente las más apretadas y y las
más hermosas que ha tenido Brasil en su
historia por el nivel de división que
han generado ahora pues los candidatos
sólo les queda esperar a que mañana
abran las jornadas muy temprano a las 8
de la mañana o una jornada electoral que
Esperamos sea pacífica y Bueno pues
nosotros vamos a seguir aquí en la
paulista viendo cómo pasan los locos Y
cómo avanza la jornada